[Music]
both restaurants begin all out to win
with a classic Spanish ingredient pork
favored for his amazing versatility
Forks have a tough me to get right and
where's overcook nothing worse dry
outside a dining room full of VIPs all
with a passion for Spanish food will
help me judge both dishes tonight
including renowned Spanish familiar
Bruno Marciano and the Spanish
ambassador Don Karl Aires Casa who Ana
epaulette all the front of house teams
can do is wait and hope
an order empanada four covers Table five
four big cheeks
yes no thank you
after my secret diners bombshell Nomar
is putting everything on the line
tonight with an incredibly complex dish
he's mixing the refined with the rustic
a rich pig's Trotter
Quadra and ham on Wellington so with a
sweet fig puree will sit alongside some
of the cheapest cuts with a big slow
braised tongue and cheeks
they are the ugly hats on the pork you
need to be very skilful to make the best
out of them whether you're very
confident I've tasted all the food I'm
very happy with the flavors the
combination of them all together so
hopefully they won't like it
ha ha so you really are going all out
there there's a lot going on there a lot
of going on the combination I think it
just fantastic in the mouth seriously
ambitious I mean it's like three dishes
on that one plate
he's obsessed we've been so quirky I
just hope the sort of balance of that
dish comes together and is not to
weighted
on order four covers Table five Fino
four pork cutlets yes yes core guys
please at least give me an answer look
it's not it's not complet you know in
her own kitchen never else is a control
freak shouting orders left right and
center but today she's like a different
person
I want to hear that communication and a
little bit of oomph please I hope her
silence doesn't mean she's lost her
nerves on order four covers table one
fee no for pork cutlets yes yeah good
now it's sounding like a professional
kitchen let's go yeah today Nevers is
sticking to her bass crews creating a
simple dish packed with authentic
flavors
pork cutlets marinated in sweet paprika
accompanied by a silky smooth
cauliflower puree and broad beans cooked
with Hummel painters fence you're
keeping it exactly what you took like
you fee know this is bunnies that's what
I do
for simple things on the plate we're
tasting amazing together yeah always
love it
good hope you like was everyone thank
you thank you
with vino I'm expecting magic she's kept
it simple it has to be perfect every
element on there for cutlets away how
long give me a tight I'm ready good no
that looks fantastic
love the colors vibrant shouting summer
okay look again beautiful absolutely
fantastic yeah through those double
check please go
here we go guys yeah fruit looking
amazing it's incredible they're just so
focused and getting their dishes
absolutely spot-on
so focused I mean that's the most focus
I've seen any chef in this competition
nervous is lavishing her complete
attention on each dish letting the
ingredients speak for themselves diverse
yes - pork away I'll say what please yes
fantastic go Oliver
happy yes yes go please
Table four oh that's very nice more than
good job torture but will my diners be
wild or underwhelmed by the simplicity
of a dish you'd lend cloth leather
collars here nice combination very very
nicely besides there's only three go